- What is the one thing about mixing
that people don't understand?
(upbeat music)
And in this particular film, the dialogue,
were two major issues.
One is that everybody's had to decide
what kind of accent we should have-
- Mm-hmm.
- And I decided
that everybody should be
speaking American English
with an Italian accent, as if
they were native born Italians
in America and had learned English.
But it also brings with it a
question of intelligibility.
I decided that place
names should be in Italian
and proper nouns should be in
Italian and spoken in Italian.
- And this outside capital
will magically bestow
its favors upon Maserati.
- What did that pose for you
in terms of intelligibility
and how the dialogue tracks came in?
- When we were working together,
you were very aware of cadences,
of how an Italian star
would drop off more-
- Right, yeah.
- At the end of a sentence and things.
So we did quite a lot
of volume manipulation
with certain syllables
as well at the ends too.
- And you really are
talking about syllables
is because we would drop-
- Yes.
- Just the very end of
a syllable of a word.
I recall that we found that
sometimes shortening a vowel,
if an accent wasn't quite right,
particularly on an American actor,
speaking Italian accent
in American English,
if the accent, it wasn't right,
it was typically because
they were drawing out
like an A-
- Yes.
- [Michael] Of this word Chicago.
Chicago.
- When you and I first worked
together many years ago now,
we could never do that on film because-
- I know.
- We couldn't get in
that close on the magnetic tape.
- It was our first film, Heat.
- [Andy] I came in right at
the very end of Mohicans,
but Heat was the one-
- Heat!
- We first worked on together, yeah.
Thinking of motor itself.
one of the fun scenes that
I enjoyed doing the most
for the sound was actually
the Maserati time trial.
I can't remember if it was
fully in the script like that,
where we were cutting backwards
and forwards to the church
with the Mozart going
back onto the Maserati.
The beauty of that with
the rawness of the engine,
the gorgeous vocal, the gorgeous singing.
And then, of course,
we introduced all the
fun of the stopwatches.
They were at church, but
really they were listening to,
they heard the gun go off
for the beginning of the time trial.
- [Michael] Right.
- And they all switched
their watches on 'em,
and that was such a great
sort of juxtaposition
of all those different sounds.
It was definitely one of
the most fun things to do.
The opera scene was also a
very special moment I thought
for sound because it was a little opposite
of what we would normally do.
We started in the opera house,
we hear the distant singing,
which Laura's hearing 'cause
she hasn't gone to the opera,
now (indistinct) is hearing
and she's not there.
(opera music)
We cut to the opera house,
we hear it in its beauty,
and by the way, they were
recorded live singing.
- [Michael] Right.
- So that was a challenge,
but again, very authentic.
(opera music)
Then we go on stage with
them and we dried it all out.
We took the reverbs down a lot
so we weren't suddenly in
the opera house anymore.
We became more intimate.
And I think that was an interesting choice
that you asked me to do-
- Yeah.
- But it worked so beautifully
because now suddenly
you've lost a performance
and you've gone into what
they're all thinking.
- Right.
- As you cut to each person.
(opera music)
As you see their eyes-
- Well, the design, yeah.
- [Andy] You read something into that.
- My design for that scene
was to invert the performance.
I wanted opera singers lit
as if they were the subjects
of the scene.
- Yes.
- And not the actors.
Yeah, and the camera
work is very intimate,
it's very verite right in their faces,
as if the two characters
we're the most familiar with,
the tenor and the soprano,
singing the aria from traviata.
Then the audience, our characters,
Enzo Ferrari, Lina Lardy,
Shailene Woodley, what opera does to you,
it invokes memory, and
then what's most alive
is their flashbacks and
what they're recalling.
And each one, it became an opportunity
to explore the backstory
in totally emotional terms
of young Enzo Ferrari, young
Laura when Dino was three,
four years old, and Enzo's dancing
with the dress in the 1930s,
and he's singing part of the aria.
- Mmm, the aria.
- So it's like a three-way-
- Yeah.
- Perspective,
all of which is then cut through
with the savage red car racing at you.
- The French Grand Prix.
- Very abrupt cut to
the French Grand Prix.
(car revving)
In this film, you had to deal
with the sound of the cars,
and it is music.
- Absolutely.
- But the sound of the
cars, the authentic sound
of not regular, commercial B12s,
but full competition B12
Ferrari engines, is powerful,
it's beautiful, it's scary, it's inviting,
it's all these things
all at the same time.
(car revving)
We had done a lot of temp with
various different car sounds
when we were editing.
We always, with the
intention of going back
and then recording-
- Yeah, yeah.
- The real thing.
- Yeah, the real thing.
- Which we eventually did.
Do you wanna talk about how to,
how we managed the extreme dynamics?
- (chuckles) So obviously,
you had to create cars
that you could put cameras in
and would go at a good speed.
You got 'em up to a hundred,
120 miles an hour, those-
- We would do 130, 140.
- Yep.
But obviously, they didn't
have quite that sound.
So we were able to access the vehicles,
put them out into a little
race trap in England,
and record just sound only.
- Right.
- So that's how we created the
sound of the real vehicles.
As far as the dynamics
go, a lot of that is down
to the way that the script
and the way you shot it,
the way it was cut.
- Right.
- Because it had these
hard sort of juxtapositions
all the time, which was so great.
You'd get a very intense dialogue scene,
which allowed us to strip backgrounds
and things out of and become
very almost claustrophobic-
- Right.
- In the drama-
- Yeah.
- Between our characters.
And then you, on a cut,
we'd go into full-blooded roar of engines.
(car skidding and revving)
I mean, that, from a sound point of view,
was actually a lot of fun to do.
When you think about music,
that's also a big component
because how can music be more exciting
than the sound of those real engines?
Is it, tackling a period piece like this,
is it hard for the
specificity of the period
and the location?
- My ambition is to bring
audience into the world.
The amount of detail and everything
that I would wanna bring into it
to make it complete is vast.
This is where everything really happens.
- Right.
- So you pick up a residence
off walking through the real place,
but it's completely unchanged.
- Really?
- And there's nothing built
after the 19th century
in the whole of three-fifths of motordom
- [Andy] Oh.
- So everywhere you look,
the cobblestone streets,
everything is totally period.
There's a lot of signage
you had to take off.
The Ferrari house is
actually Piero's house,
and if we walk around the
corner from the Ferrari house,
there's a barbershop where
he gets shaved every morning.
So Adam sat in a chair that Enzo sat in
and was shaved in the film
by the son of the barber-
- On the set, oh my god.
- Who shaved Enzo.
- [Andy] That's fantastic.
- So there was so much of that resonance.
In mixing, it's the final writing,
it's the final authoring of the movie,
and you have every
component, it's not a script,
which is a blueprint of what
you want to have happen,
and it's not the shooting,
which is so fragmented.
When you're mixing, it
is all there for real.
- Right.
- Okay?
It's all around you.
What is the one thing about mixing
that people don't understand?
- If you notice something,
then it's probably not right.
What I try and aim to do
is make you not notice
that we're doing anything particularly
with the soundtrack, you know?
Because if you start to hear
things that confuse you,
then you've lost people.
Clarity is number one to me,
it's always been the same way.
- Right.
- I've mixed in a very
traditional style, as you know.
It's about making sure that
it's very clear, the storyline,
the narrative, the atmospheres
are very important around that.
And then of course, the
music, the music choices,
where the music comes
in, where it goes out.
- Right.
- They're all signals
that you're supposed to pay
attention to subconsciously.
If it's in the wrong place,
you notice it for the wrong reasons.
- Right.
- So what I try and do every day
is make something as
seamless and as meant to be
as it can be for that story.
- [Michael] It's the flow of
the narrative through times.
- Absolutely.
- And the rhythm of that
flow from quiet scenes
to loud scenes to when
you have the juxtaposition
of a dynamic sound coming on.
That's what's particularly exciting.
- [Andy] It is exciting.
- That I rely on you very much
to be able to calm me down
and keep it in a-
- I do my best.
And often, you and I will sit
and we'll go through something
and then you'll go back
and make an adjustment
in the editing room with the picture.
- Right.
- Because it only becomes
apparent while we're mixing sound
that the picture needs
to have an adjustment.
- [Michael] When we mix,
I move the editing rooms
on the mixing stage,
basically an adjacent
room, so that we can make-
- Yeah, constant adjustments.
- Because it really is totally-
- Yeah.
- It's interactive and organic.
- [Andy] It's very interactive.
- It's very much alive.
- Yep.
- It's the best of times
when I get to park the car
in front of the sound stage and go in
and I'm there every minute.
- Yes, you are.
- With you.
(chuckling)
And it's really, it's a real pleasure.
I keep, I always look forward to it.
- Great, well, me too, thank you.
- I think that's a good endpoint.
- Thank you, it's been
great talking to you.
Thank you so much.
- Good.
Yeah, you're welcome.
(upbeat music)